my inbox is full of hate mails and
personal abuse and has been for years
in 2010 I started answering those Mays
and suggesting to the rider that we
might meet for coffee and a chat I have
had hundreds of encounters they have
told me something important that I want
to share with you I was born in Turkey
from from Kurdish parents and we moved
to Denmark when I was a young child in
2007 I ran for a seat in the Danish
Parliament as one of the first women
with a minority background I was
selected but I soon found out that not
everyone was happy about it as I had to
quickly get used to finding hate
messages in my inbox this emails will
begin with something like this
what's Iraq had like you doing in our
Parliament I never answered I just
delete the emails I just thought that
the send us and I had nothing in common
they didn't understand me and I didn't
understand them then one day one of my
colleagues and the Parliament said that
I should save the hate mails when
something happens to you it'll give the
police a lead
I noticed that she said when something
happens and not if sometimes hateful
letters were also sent to my home
address the more I became involved in
public debate the more hate mails and
threats I received after a while I got a
secret address and I had to check extra
precautions to protect my family
then in 2010 and Nazi began to harass me
it was a man who had attacked Muslim
women on the street over time it became
much worse I was had to sue with my
children and the phone was ringing
constantly it was a Nazi I had the
impression that he was close we had at
home when we got back my son asked why
does she hate you so much mom when he
doesn't even know you
some people are just stupid I said and
at the time I actually thought that was
a pretty clever answer and I suspect
that that is the answer most of us would
give the others yeah is a stupid
brainwash it ignorant we are the good
guys and they are the bad guys period
several weeks later I was at a friend's
house and I was very upset and angry
about all the hate and racism I had met
it was he who suggested I should call
them up and visit them they will kill me
I said they would never attack the
member of the Danish Parliament he said
and anyway if they killed you you'd
become a martyr
so it's pure win-win situation for you
his advice was so unexpected when I got
home I turn on my computer and open the
folder where I have saved all the hate
mails there were literally hundreds of
them emails had started with words like
Tara's rag head rat hole I decided to
contact the one who had sent me the most
his name was English I decided to
contact him just once so I could say at
least I had tried to my surprise and
shock he answer the phone I blurted out
hello my name is awesome you have sent
me so many hate mess you don't know me I
don't know of you I was wondering if I
could come around and we can drink our
coffee together and talk about it there
was silence on the line and then he said
I have to ask my wife what the racist
has a wife a couple of days later we met
at his house I will never put it when he
opened his front door and reach out to
shake my hand I felt so disappointed
because he looked nothing like I'd
imagined I had expected a horrible
person dirty messy house it was not his
house melt of coffee which was served
from a coffee set identical to the one
my parents use I ended up for staying
two and a half hours and we had so many
thing in common even our prejudices were
alike
Bingle told me that when he wait for the
bus and the bus stop 10 minutes away
from him it was because the trial was a
racket
I recognize that feeling when I was
young and I wait for the bus and it
stopped 10 meters away from me I was
sure that the driver was a racist when I
got home I was very ambivalent about my
experience on the one hand I really
liked Engel he was easy and pleasant to
talk to but on the other hand I couldn't
stand the idea of having so much in
common with someone who had such clearly
racist views gradually and painfully I
came to realize that I had been just of
just mental of those who had sent me
hate mails as they have been of me this
was the beginning what I call hashtag
dialogue coffee basically I sit down for
coffee with people who had written the
most terrible things to me to try to
understand why they hate people like me
and they don't even know me I have been
doing this the last eight years the vast
majority of people I approach agree to
meet me most of them are men but I also
met women I have married a rule to
always meet them in their house to
convey from the outset that I trust them
I always bring food because when we eat
together it is easier to find what we
have in common and make peace together
along the way I have learned some
valuable lessons the people who sent
hate mails are workers husbands wives
parents like you and me
I'm not saying that their behavior is
acceptable but I have learned to these
things
myself from the hateful views without
this thanks in myself from the person
who's expressing those views and I have
discovered that the people I visit are
just as afraid of people they don't know
as I was afraid of them before I invite
sudden inviting myself for coffee during
those meetings as specific themes keeps
coming up it's show up regardless where
I am talking to a humanist or racist a
man a woman and Muslim on a dais they
all seems to think that other people are
to blame for the hate and for the
generalization of groups they all
believe that other people have to stop
demonizing they point at politician the
media their neighbor or the bus driver
who stops 10 metres away but when I
asked what about you what can you do the
replies usually what can I do I have no
influence I have no power
I know that feeling for large part of my
life I also thought that I don't have
any power and influence even when I was
a member of the Danish Parliament but
today I know the reality is different we
all have power and influence where we
are so we must never never underestimate
our own potential the dollar coffee
meetings have taught me that people of
all political convictions can be caught
demonizing the orders with different
views I know what I'm talking about
as a young time I hated different
population groups at the time my
religious views were very extreme but my
friendship with jerks with Danes with
Jews and the traces has vaccinated me
against my own prejudices I grew up in a
working-class family and on my journey I
have met
many people who have insisted on
speaking to me they have changed my
views they have formed me as a
democratic citizen and a bridge builder
if we want to prevent hate and violence
we have to talk to as many people as
possible for as long as possible while
being as open as possible that can only
be achieved through debate critical
conversation and insisting on dialogue
that doesn't demonize people I'm going
to ask you a question I invite you to
think about it when you get home and in
the coming days
but you have to be honest with yourself
it should be easy no one else will know
it
the question is this who do you luminize
do you think supporters of American
President Trump are deplorable or that
those who voted for Turkish president
air Doan are crazy
Islamists know that those who voted for
lepen in France are stupid fascist now
perhaps you think that Americans who
voted for Bernie Sanders are immature
hippies all those words have been used
to clarify those groups maybe at this
point do you think I am an idealist I
want to give you a challenge before the
end of this year I challenge you to
invite someone who you demonize someone
who you disagree with politically and
all culturally and don't think you have
anything in common with I challenge you
to invite someone like the siddhaloka
remember guys basically I'm asking you
to find an English in your life
contact him or her and suggest that you
can meet $4
when you start a Dalek off you have to
remember this first don't give up if the
person refuses at first sometimes is
tech me nearly one year to arrange a
dollar coffee meeting to acknowledge the
other person's courage
it isn't just us brave the one who is
inviting you into their homes is just a
spray 3 bank-shot during the
conversation make sure the most of the
conversation focuses on what we have in
common as I said bring food and finally
remember to finish the conversation in a
positive way because you are going to
meet again a bridge can't be built in
one day we are living in a world where
many people hold definitive and often
extreme opinions about the others
without knowing much about them you
notice of course the prejudices on the
other side than on our own basis and we
banned them from our lives we believe
the hate mails we hang out only with
people who think like us and talk about
the others in Category often stain the
unfriend people on Facebook and when we
meet people whose discriminating a
dehumanizing people are groups it done
insist on speaking to it them to
challenge their opinions
that's how healthy democratic societies
break down when we don't check the
personal responsibility for the
democracy we take the democracy for
granted
it is not conversation is the most
difficult thing in a democracy and also
the most important so here's my
challenge fine you are English
start a conversation chances have been
dug between people yes but we all have
the ability to build the bridges that
cross the trenches and let me end by
quoting my friend
Sergio to Jean who lost his son venosum
in a chair attack on a Jew synagogue in
Copenhagen 2015 subject rejected any
suggestion of revenge and instead said
this
evil can only be defeated by kindness
between people kindness
demands courage dear friends let's be
courageous thank you
[Applause]